[Music]
well I finally finished up the high
school musical trilogy with High School
Musical 2 I know that's not the last one
but I actually saw the last one first
the first one second and the second one
last yep that's entirely out of order so
I'll just jump right into it when I pop
this movie in I'm not gonna lie I was
blown away this opening is amazing
probably the best thing I've seen out of
all the movies first off it has a
legitimately funny intro the kids are
all waiting for high school to end and
summer to start and the clock behind the
teacher literally gets bigger every
single time that cuts back to her that's
so clever it could be a John Hughes joke
then the song singing about summer break
starts and I'm not gonna lie it left me
kind of speechless
they must have thrown everything into
this one musical number look at the
dancing look at the movement look at how
they're utilizing everything around them
look at the creativity in these steps
how many things can they do with a
basketball and dancing damn they find
just about everything you can do with it
look at the editing look at the
camerawork look at what a grand scale
this is and on top of that parts of the
film and legitimately good jokes
yeah not jokes like oh it's for kids I
guess I'll laugh no legitimately funny
jokes
I love these yuppie parents they use
their kids as balance the scene
demonstrating how bad kid golfers can be
is downright hilarious
good job killer make the ball fear you I
actually rewind the film to hear that
line again and maybe laugh so hard it's
also the only High School Musical to
show the bloopers and they're pretty
funny too so yeah an unbelievable
opening followed by some real good
laughs and an all-around in movie yeah
if you thought this was the one that was
finally gonna win me all the way over
you're tapping to a different tune well
it does have some of the best parts of
any of the movies it's still on par with
say that season of Saved by the Bell
where they all got jobs at a resort over
summer vacation
you remember that of course you know if
you're watching this you're not new 30s
summer begins and everybody just so
happens to get a job at of course a
fashionable resort owned by Sharpay's
parents shar-pei decides for the
resort's talent show she wants Zac Efron
as her co-host this of course angers her
incestuous brother okay I'm not doing
one who sees this right tell me somebody
else
of course he his girlfriend Gabriella
and all his friends want to be in the
talent show too but sure Pei thinks
there's too many people and tries to of
course sabotage him into only working
with her okay pretty lame but it is made
a little bit more interesting when her
parents seem to be opening a lot of
doors for scholarships and good schools
this makes him more susceptible to
Sharpay and even easier letting his
friends go while doing the talent show
in the grand scheme of things is not a
big deal they do make kind of a bigger
deal that he is sort of manipulating
himself and changing himself to open
doors and he doesn't know how much to
hold on to and how much to give up this
is kind of an interesting subject to
talk about and sometimes they do treat
it very seriously but the problem is
it's dealt with a lot better in the
third one when all the kids are
graduating they're trying to figure out
what to do where to go what colleges
they're gonna be at splitting up
discovering who they want to be and yeah
it's just done better more realistic
more thought-provoking and this is just
the typical you're letting that girl
brainwash you man who are you I don't
know who you are anymore
granted it's done a little bit more
delicately and they don't entirely make
sure pay the villain but the version I
saw is almost two hours and it feels
like it when they try telling jokes and
doing visual humor it works but a lot of
the drama and yeah even a lot of a song
numbers aren't exactly that strong I
feel like they open with too strong of a
punch that first musical number was such
a big deal that nothing in the rest of
the movie could possibly top it so a lot
of it just kind of meanders a good half
of it is then just moping around the
resort and skipping in kitchens okay
we're wine that we got to see that again
can somebody explain what this is and
while nothing in it is certainly bad it
doesn't really all gel together either I
remember kind of looking at my watch
saying man how long is this movie can we
get to the funny stuff again or can you
throw um them a basketball I don't know
just do something like what you were
doing before but yeah when it gets to
those enjoyably corny scenes they are
enjoyably corny the last Madhu with that
pops up at the end had me laughing so
hard when it's revealed who he's gonna
do the duet with that I had a pause that
I was laughing so much you just shrug
and lovingly say only the Disney Channel
would give us something sociable see and
like I said that's
surprisingly doesn't bother me that's
part of the fun for me it's just when
it's slow serious and been done a
million times adding nothing really do
it by no means does it throughout the
entire film but it does it through a lot
that you do kind of move around in your
seat a bit there's not even a high
school musical in it the first one we
don't get to see the High School Musical
on this one that they just write it out
of the entire movie talk about false
advertising does it need to exist no
does it really further the characters
that much not really but again there are
some very impressive very creative and
even very funny scenes I guess if you
liked the first one you'll like this one
enough I'd be lying if I said I didn't
want to see some parts again either to
laugh or just admire how well
choreographed it is kind of a mixed bag
but that's High School Musical in a
nutshell to me get your dance shoes on
and check it out for yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
you